l'union libre être livre des députés
socialistes veulent la codifier et à
l'image de l'autre union le mariage il
propose la mise au point d'un contrat
d'union civile qui comporterait
évidemment des droits inexistant
aujourd'hui mais aussi des devoirs
béatrice nivois avait poggio en france 2
millions de couples vivant en union
libre un enfant sur trois naît hors
mariage pour cela qu'ils ont refusé un
engagement rigide un projet de contrat
d'union civile se propose de leur donner
des garanties notamment bénéficié de la
sécurité sociale de l'autre ou en cas de
décès ne pas débourser des droits
successoraux plus importants que ceux
des couples légitimes
je travaille à la disposition
législative qui permettrait à ceux qui
vivent ensemble sans être mariés et
pouvoir régler plus facilement quelques
problèmes pratiques de la vie
quotidienne comme acheter ou louer un
logement sans nous régler les problèmes
de file des chutes et nyon lors que l'un
des deux est faible les dispositions
pratiques juridiques qui permettraient
l'égalité des droits pour toutes du même
coup les couples homosexuels
bénéficierait de tous ces avantages et
verrait leur union reconnu ce qu'il
demande depuis des années et là commence
le vrai débat alors s'il faut faire une
loi pour mot sexuelle ou d'un droit pour
homosexuels
moi je veux bien mais c'est certainement
pas le même que pour un homme et une
femme qui vivent sans bien sûr que ça
concerne des homosexuels et des années d
hétérosexuels mais ça peut considérer
qu'on concernés par exemple de vieilles
dames qui vivent ensemble tout
simplement parce que parce que la
solitude c'est difficile et puis ça
coûte moins cher d'avoir un seul
logement
sur les neuf articles de ce projet
concerne les enfants il prévoit
l'autorité parentale conjointe
là aussi les détracteurs du texte donne
la réponse il ya deux solutions ou bien
les gens qui vivent hors mariage
souhaite continuer à vivre par mariage
ou bien espagne nous marier le mariage
ça sert à ça
cet après midi les députés du groupe
socialiste ont étudié le projet mais de
là à le présenter à l'assemblée il y
encore un pas qu'ils n'ont pas franchi
tant il est vrai que ce projet
bouleverserait plus la morale que le
cadre juridique
en tout cas le contrat d'union civile ne
prévoit pas comme le mariage une clause
la fidélité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]